kans population triples when the Film
Festival is in town from 70 to 200
thousand but for the creme de la creme
there's only a handful of choices to be
honest II in can they think festival
started already two weeks ago because
the day preparation inside the each of
them but also in the old city this is
crazy
Claudia runs the Martinez Hotel the
place to be and be seen in calm since
the 1920s
tonight it's hosting the festival's jury
including President Jane Campion you can
mingle with the a-listers by the pool or
on the hotel's private beach the largest
and can the cheapest room at the
Martinez during the festival is one
thousand and eighty dollars but the one
thousand square meter penthouse one of
the biggest in Europe will cost fifty
two thousand dollars prices more than
double during the festival but rooms
here aren't just for sleeping one third
of the tests have been completely
transformed and most of the Suites are
becoming showrooms offices brands like
jeweler shopper who make the top award
the Palme d'Or and L'Oreal are based
here for the hotel yeah it's like two
weeks of the Oscars you can't imagine
that the pressure and you can't imagine
what we have to do on a daily basis is
really at this level one of the longest
event all over the year all over the
world
Angus Bennett can't Bloomberg